Welcome back. So now that we have done some little bit of manipulation and cleaning on
the original dataset, let's pick up where we left off and try to see if we can do any
serious data exploration, any statistical analysis on the dataset. So as usual, let's
import the Pandas library and the plotting library, which is matplotlib, and run the
dataset to import them. Now, as usual, at the end of the last notebook, you must have
seen that we had written this data to this particular path. We had a folder called data
within which we created this file caggle clean, and we're just going to read it back again
and look at the first five rows of the dataset. So you see, we still have the same problem.
That is, our first column is still text and our header is obviously already text. So this
data is still not completely numerical. If we were to again take the histogram of all the
durations in this dataset, we'd still run into the same problem where it'll say that it can't
compare these values against a particular string. And that is why we essentially have to figure out
a way to drop this entire row and see where we can include that data so that only we are
restricted to crunching the data that is present in rows one onwards. So let's see what we can do
that. Now, one of the arguments that the read CSV function accepts is something called a header.
Now, by default, if you don't provide that argument, when we read the data for the first
time using the read CSV function, we did not tell it what its header was supposed to be.
So usually it simply takes the first row as the header. It assumes that there is a header
and the first row is the header. If there is no header, then you explicitly have to tell it that
there is no header. But of course, in this particular case, our header is not just one
column. It's actually two columns. You see that this row is actually a header, but it has started
coming in as the first column. So what we're doing here is we're telling it that take the
zeroth row as the header and also take the first row as the header. So basically our header should
span two rows. So let's do that and see what it shows us again. There we have, you see that now
our header is spanning this row and the first row as well. And now the data starts correctly coming
in from the zeroth row onwards. But at the same time, you see that our header has grown a little
complicated. For example, earlier when I wanted to refer to this particular column, I just used
call name as the string time from start to finish in seconds. And I use that call name to access the
data. As you know, I can just put the name of a column within the square brackets and call it on
the data frame to get a particular column out of the data frame. But here, since my data frame has
gotten a little complicated because of the header, I don't know what to do with this extra text. So
here's one way to do it. If we simply look at the columns, here's what it's going to give me.
It basically tells me that it's a multi-index instead of a single index as we have seen earlier.
What a multi-index means is that the data is being indexed by two values, not one value. So
essentially earlier we had rows or rather columns which were indexed just by this particular header.
Now we have columns which are being indexed by two headers at a time, not one header. So that's
what a multi-index means. It basically says that time from start to finish is also a descriptor,
as well as duration in seconds is also another descriptor. So if you look at the first column,
which is basically q1, this was the zeroth column. If you look at the first column which is q1,
it will basically give me this data set. Now you see that this is not a single column. It's
basically creating another column which has a column within itself and that is basically
the second header. So it's sort of a hierarchy. You see that q1 is basically the top level column
and under that there is another column. So that's how it's interpreting that. And if we were actually
to pick those two columns together, then it would give me the raw column itself completely.
And if you look at the name of this column, you see that it's giving us a tuple. From the first
video that we saw on python, we know that tuple is basically one of the data structures. And it
says that this tuple has two elements, one is q1 and the second is what is your age in years.
And that actually matches this. We see that q1 and what is your age in years are basically two
different column headers and both of them here are required to refer to the same data. This is
very complicated. So what we are going to do is try and make it more manageable. We are going to
keep only the first level of indexing on the data frame and the second we are going to keep
only for reference. So basically what we are going to do is we are going to tell pandas that only
consider this particular row as the header. And this we are going to basically delete, but we are
going to keep it separately somewhere so that later if we forget what q6 is, we can always look it up
in a particular lookup table or dictionary where we can say that okay I might have forgotten what
q6 is, but this is what it means. q6 corresponds to the question which asks what is the size of
the company where you are employed. So in order to keep accessing the data, we are simply going to
keep these codes, but their meanings we are going to throw away from the table but maintain in a
separate dictionary somewhere. So let's try and do that. So basically one quick way to do that is
use something called a dictionary comprehension. As we know, we can create dictionaries by using
something like this. So as you know we can create dictionaries using a pair of braces and I can say
something like this is my key and my value and then I have another key and another value something
like that. So that basically creates my dictionary. One quick way to create a dictionary is using
something called a dictionary comprehension. So what it's going to do is essentially you keep the
braces as they are but inside instead of writing a set of key value pairs. Now of course we can't
write the whole set of 246 key value pairs as I present here. What we want essentially is a dictionary
where the question codes are my keys and the text of the question is the value. So I can just put
the question code in that dictionary and get the question corresponding to that code. That's the
kind of dictionary I want. One quick way to do that is to use a dictionary comprehension where I say
that k colon v for k comma v in df.columns. Now df.columns since it is a multi-index is going to
iterate over both these lists. The first level which is the question code and the second level
which is the question text. So k becomes my question code and v becomes my question text and that
gives me this whole dictionary. It basically is a massive python dictionary which says that q1
is a key which corresponds to what is your age, q2 is a key which corresponds to what is your gender,
q4 is the question which corresponds to what is the highest level of formal education that you have
and so on. So let's scroll all the way down it's going to be pretty large because
there are 246 questions. Much easier way is to simply use the dict function. Remember that just
like we use the list function to create lists you can use the dict function to create dictionaries
and you can simply call this on df.columns. df.columns is simply a multi-index column which
means that it has key values everywhere and we do that we basically get the same data again.
So this is an easier way to do it rather than using dictionary complications. Of course one
of them might be suitable for a certain application and you should be aware of what both of them do.
So now since we know which codes corresponds to which question we can get rid of the second
level of columns. So what we're going to do is create a new dictionary called question codes
and that is essentially this particular dictionary. You have the keys as the question
codes and the values as the text of the question and that creates my question codes and after that
I'm going to create a new data frame which I'll be calling xdf simply as a modification of my
original data frame and I'm going to say that drop level. So drop level is a function which tells
pandas to drop a level of index from the data set. If we go all the way back to our data frame
there's actually a lot of text here what we can do is simply remove this. So I can say clear output
and here too I can say clear output. So we have a little more room to scroll around now.
If we go back to the data we see that my header is present in two levels. This is the first level
and this is the second level. Now obviously that means that this is the zeroth level and this is
the first level. So what I'm going to simply do is ask pandas to drop the first level along the
first axis. Remember we have seen that when we talk of the zeroth axis we are talking about
row wise stuff whereas when we talk about the first axis we are talking about column wise stuff.
Here our second level of indexing is happening along the columns not along the rows. Remember
that the rows are still indexed with a single number. So we are simply going to drop that first
thing and there it is. Now when we look at xdf.head we have a lot cleaner data set. We just have the
question codes and we have the values. But of course now what if I how do I find out what q1
means? Well I've already created a dictionary called question codes right and there I can just
put in q1 and I say that okay q1 does correspond to what is your age and then q2 also correspondingly
corresponds to this question what is your gender. So there it is. We have a column q2 which
corresponds to gender and here's an exercise. How would we find the gender ratio of this survey?
So pause the video for a while take a minute to think about it and do the exercise. We already
know how to get a particular column out of pandas. We just do df square brackets put in the name of
the column that gives you the whole column. So one of the things we might want to do simply is to
calculate all the males and females and find their ratio essentially. So essentially the point is
counting how many males are there counting how many females are there. There could be other
genders also so be aware of that and see what are the proportions of different genders. So feel free
to look around feel free to google and here we are going to introduce some of the more
advanced pandas functionality and we'll do that as soon as we resume.
So let's take a shot at how we would do this. In order to find the gender ratio that is in what
proportion the different genders are present. First of all I have to find out what all different
values are there. So male and female I can already see here but note that I am looking at all I am
looking at only five rows out of the 19,718 rows. So let's say that we want to find out all the
possible values that people have put in under Q2 which is gender. So let's say that we create an
empty list called gender and then we are going to iterate through this row. So what I can do then is
for gender in df Q2 which is genders. By the way dot values is what actually lets you iterate through
the values that's essentially the list of genders. So let's say that we want to find out all the
values that's essentially the list which is the underlying data structure of a particular column
and I'm going to say that if gender is already in genders
remember that in is something we use to check membership in a list. So this is a list which
is currently empty and we are going to keep on accumulating the different genders that we see.
So if the gender that we have in a particular row of Q2 is already in this list then we do nothing
which means continue the iteration or then if it is not inside the gender then we can simply do
genders not append of gender. So we are going to keep on appending to this dictionary and at the
end we are just going to say print genders. So again to take a look at this in a little more
detail we have created an empty list which contains all the genders in that data set
and we are going to iterate through that column and we say that if the gender that is in a
particular iteration is already present in my list if gender in genders then I simply continue
I don't do anything but if it is not there then I'm simply going to append that gender to my
genders and then at the end once the for loop is done I'm going to print out the list of all the
accumulated genders. So there it is. So we see that we have four things we have something like
there is male there is female there is one option says prefer to self-describe
and the other one says prefer not to say. Now one easy way of doing that is instead of all of this
for loop jugglery I can simply do df Q2 which is my column and I can simply do a unique statement on
it. Well same data for attribute oh of course we had xdf not simply df because xdf was something
that we created after dropping the first level of hierarchy so let's do it on xdf and there it is.
So we get the same four values back again this time without using the for loop. So this is a method
that is already built into pandas use it whenever you can whenever you find yourself writing too
much extra code that's probably a good signal that you might just want to look up in the
documentation and try to find something that does the job for you ready mate. So there it is these
are all the unique genders. Now the next thing that we have to do is basically count how many
males are there how many females are there how many people prefer to self-describe and how many
people prefer not to say. So what we are going to do is simply create a list of counts and let us
say that I create a dictionary called counts where I say male is zero female is zero
prefer to self-describe is a key again which is zero and prefer not to say
is yet another key which has a value of zero. Now what I'm going to do is again iterate through
this list so let's say for gender in xdf of q2.values I'm just going to say my count is basically
from the counts I'm just going to get the gender. Now I know that this value of gender is going to
be one of the keys present here can't be a fifth key because I already know what are all the unique
values that I have and those are the ones that I've put in this dictionary. Now since counts is
my dictionary and gender is one of the values in the row whenever I get this initially it's going
to be zero and since I have found that particular gender I'm just going to increment my count so
I'm just going to take whatever value is already accumulated there and add one to it and then I'm
going to put that value back into the dictionary. So essentially this is getting the count access
this step increments the count and this step steps back the count adds the count back to the
dictionary and then I say print counts. So there we are we have 15,890 males 3,178 males
48 people prefer to self-describe and 303 people prefer not to say. So that's basically the total
number of all types of genders that we have. One quick way to simply get the ratio is divide each
of these values by the total number of rows that are present and like we know the total number of
rows that are present can be obtained by saying xdf.shape where 19419 is basically the number of
filtered rows and 246 is still the number of columns. So I have something like in rows note
that this is a tuple and the first value in the tuple is going to be the number of rows so I can
say n rows equal to xdf.shape of zero because that gets me the zeroth element of the tuple
and then I'm going to say that for gender and count
that's probably a bad idea we don't want to iterate over a dictionary and then do it again.
So at the end of it what we could simply do is
for gender count in counts.items print gender and then what we're going to do is divide count
by the number of rows multiplied by 100 and say that that's my percentage basically this is the
percentage for a given gender. So let's run that and now we know that 81 percent are males 16 percent
are females 0.24 percent prefer to self-describe and 1.5 percent prefer not to say. Now again here
as far as possible we would like to avoid all of this jugglery again so one quick way to avoid
this is basically just to do something like this I simply take xdf I select the column that I'm
interested in and I use a new method called value underscore counts what it's going to do is it's
simply going to count each value so there it is and we have the same things again and again
we have the male which occurs 15,890 times females occur 3,178 times prefer not to say comes 303
times and those who prefer to self-describe are 48 in number. Now one quick way to convert this
into a percentage is to divide that by n rows which we have already calculated as xdf dot shape of 0
and multiplied by 100 and that gives me the same percentages that I earlier calculated so what we
see here is an example of how you can just use one line of pandas code to you know counter something
like eight lines of pure python code. Now another interesting thing is that you can since these are
you know percentages they all add up to 100 percent we can use something like a pie chart to
plot this so in order to do that remember that this is a panda series and panda series and data
frames both support excellent data visualization and plotting capabilities so I can just do
something like this plot let's say kind is pi and there we are so we have the male we have the females
and the miniscule proportions of people who say that they prefer to self-describe or prefer not
to say so this is one quick way to see what sort of proportions you have in your data you basically
use value counts you can convert it into a percentage and then plot it as a pie chart
you can of course plot it as a bunch of other things also we can also plot it as a bar chart
but ultimately the bar chart doesn't exactly apply here because we are looking at proportions
so part of whole so that's why the pie chart might make sense a lot of data visualization experts
hate pie charts for good reason there are always good or bad places to use certain kinds of charts
so be careful with what visualization you pick for what kind of a problem in this case it works
so there it is one easy way to look at different unique values and to summarize them is by looking
at different how many times each value occurs and convert it into percentages however this only works
if the number of unique values is very small remember that we had only four unique values here
in about 19 000 rows if we had something like 5000 unique values in 19 000 rows then this pie
chart would have looked like it has too many spokes so we don't want that either so make sure
that before you start doing an analysis of this kind the number of unique values that you have
is fairly small one quick way to simply check the number of unique values not the unique values
themselves is to take the column which we do like this and call n unique on it earlier we called
unique to get the unique values themselves we can call n unique to get the number of unique
values and we know that though there are four unique values over here male female prefer to
self-describe and prefer not to say right so there we are one quick way to get a bunch of
different summary statistics or univariate statistics as we have studied before for a given
column is to use the describe function that is provided for every column in a pandas data frame
so when i say i just want to do q2 dot describe here it is it straight away tells me that the
count is nineteen thousand four hundred and nineteen there are four unique values the most
frequent is male which has a frequency of this much so we know that males awkward 81 percent of
the times and that corresponds to out of nineteen thousand four hundred and nineteen fifteen thousand
eight hundred and ninety of course remember that q2 was a categorical column we have already covered
what are numerical ordinal and categorical columns q2 was an uh categorical column therefore
its descriptive statistics are going to be different than say the descriptive statistics
of a numerical column now the only numerical column we have in our data set is time from
start to finish so let's try to see what describe would tell us if i try to do a describe on that
so let's say i do an xdf and then i put in time from start to finish and then do a describe
here you see it gives me a very different set of statistics because it's a numerical column of course
count is still valid over here but now it has a mean a standard deviation it has a minimum value
of course you see that the minimum value is 60 because we had already cleaned the data in the
previous video then 25 percent 50 percent and 75 percent these are essentially the percentile
what this means is that 25 percent of all values are below 350 50 percent of them are below 547
and 75 percent of them are below 942 and the maximum value is 843 612 seconds
no idea what this guy was doing but the bigger point that we're trying to make here is that
the output of describe is different for different types of columns for numerical columns it's going
to give me summary statistics for categorical column also it's going to give me some summary
statistics but those statistics themselves are going to be different
so these were some examples of univariate data analysis let's take a look at how we can perform
a little bit of bivariate data analysis as well now specifically we have created a data set which
is clean and we have the header columns properly formatted let's take a look at the indian subset
of the data as you remember we have a dictionary called question codes which maps the question
code to the actual question so let's take a look at what q3 is and we say that you know
question q3 corresponds to country of residence so what we're going to do is take that subset
of the data which corresponds to all the indian respondents if you remember from the previous
exercise we had performed filtering on the data set which contained marks and attempts of multiple
students for a person called emily so here we are going to apply the same syntax we are going to
select the column q3 which is country of residence we are going to compare it with the string india
and that's going to return a bunch of true and false values and those true and false values are
what we are going to use to pick the rows which correspond to indian respondents out of the xdf
data frame and that subset of the data we are going to create into another variable which we
will just call india and then let's simply do india.head and there we are we see that the first
respondent is from india the fourth is from india the sixth is from india the tenth is from india
and so on so we again are looking at just five rows because we have done ahead and 246 columns
so these are all you know indian respondents so let's take a look at what kind of salaries
gaggle users indian gaggle users are earning in india so let's take a look at q10 which is the
question corresponding to salary what is your current yearly compensation in approximate u.s
dollars so let's take a look at what this data looks like
and basically you see that it gives us a lot of values it's basically
not single values but ranges of values the first respondent is saying that their yearly
compensation in approximate u.s dollars is five thousand dollars to something like seven thousand
four ninety nine dollars the fourth respondent is saying that their approximate compensation in
american dollars is from four to five thousand dollars and so on we also have some nn values
nn here means not a number which means that that was a null value this particular respondent
respondent number 10 chose not to answer this question perhaps so that is why their response
for this field is not number it's basically not applicable it's a null value now one way to simply
calculate how many null values are present in a row is by using this function called is any
basically select the column that you want and apply the is any function when we run that we see
that a bunch of things are true so this is true because the 10th respondent response compensation
is not a number the 14th ones respond response is also not a number and so on so you see that
there are a lot of values here which are true which means that a lot of indians
didn't exactly reveal the approximate salary that they earn in u.s dollars so first what we need to
do is if we have to do an exploration on salaries we have to drop these rows we have to make sure
that we only take those people whose yearly compensation at least in the broad range is
known we want to drop everything that has a nand under this particular column now to see
how many people have these null values we can just add a dot sum in front of the easing so
essentially we take the is any which is going to return this true and false false values for each
row and when we sum them up we are basically going to get the number of people who haven't
responded to this question so let's run that and we say that you know overall number of people who
did not respond to this question is 2252 and the total length of the indian subset of the data is
4729 so you know a little less than half the people have basically not answered this question
and what we need to do is drop all the rows which have na in this particular column na and
this particular column and for that we can use a function called drop any which means drop not a
number of values and we say that only use the quit q 10 column as a subset in the sense that
we are saying that from the india data frame drop all those rows for which q 10 is a null and we
want to do this again in place as earlier we don't want to create a new data frame we want to modify
the existing data frame in place and then when we take the head again of the india data set this is
what we get so you see that now we are not seeing any null values but at the same time we see that
some rows have a dollar sign in front of them you see that this particular row doesn't have a dollar
this particular row doesn't have a dollar but this one does so one of the things that we need to do
in order to perform any sort of mathematical analysis is get rid of that dollar symbol and
see if we can only focus on the numbers itself so we have seen lambda functions before basically
it's just a one line function which takes an input and performs some operation on that input
so basically we are creating a lambda function called remove dollar which takes an input x and
in that x it's going to replace the dollar with an empty string it's basically just going to
remove that dollar then on this subset the india subset we take the q 10 column which corresponds
to compensation and we are going to apply the remove dollar function what this will do is that
for every row this row this row and all the rows all the you know 4729 minus 2252 rows that we've
already dropped on that many number of rows it's going to apply the remove dollar function so when
we do that and run this again we see that this time we get something which doesn't have a dollar
so we see that the 22nd respondent had dollar in front of their output here the dollar is gone
right now another thing we need to do further step in the pre-processing is to remove the commas
because that comma is going to prevent us from interpreting these figures as numbers so the
moment you put in a comma python will not be able to convert that into a number and therefore it
will still treat the whole thing as a string instead of as a number but in order to do statistics
we need numbers so that's why just like we've removed the dollar symbol first now we are going
to remove the comma another way of another alternative to use this particular lambda function
is to use the str dot replace function that is also available on any pandas column so it's simply
going to say that take this particular column and within that wherever you find a comma replace it
with an empty string it's just like the lambda except it's you know one line less than this as
you can see so let's do that and then when we see the head we see that there are no commas
five comma triple zero dash seven comma four double nine has become five thousand hyphen seven four
nine nine so if you were to basically take this value we can interpret that as a number we can
call the int function which we have seen before to convert this into an integer now the next
big problem that we have in cleaning and pre-processing the data is that these are
not single numbers these are ranges of numbers so what we need to do is separate out this column
basically we have a salary column we need a salary minimum which is going to contain the lower bound
five thousand four thousand ten thousand zero hundred thousand and so on as the minimum range
of the values the lower bucket or the lower edge and then we need another column which contains
seven four nine nine four triple nine fourteen triple nine and so on which is the upper edge of
that particular range so what we're going to do is just like we had a str dot replace we also
have an str dot split and here what the split function does is that it takes in any string
and it's going to split every row on that string if that string is found so here the splitter that
we are using is a hyphen so essentially what it's going to do is every time it sees a hyphen it's
going to take everything before it and create a separate element out of it and then it's going
to take everything after it and create a separate element out of that so let's try that so that's how
we see it's basically going to split on whatever splitter we provide and the remaining parts it's
basically going to convert into a list so five thousand hyphen seven four double nine became a
list which contains five thousand as the first element and seven four double nine as the second
element and the same process has been carried over for the entire range so let's try that so
in order to keep this data as a new column in our data frame we are going to create a new column
called salary range and that we are going to simply assign to this particular function we
are going to take a column and call str dot split we are simply going to create a new
column called salary range which takes the q10 column and calls the str dot split with the hyphen
as the delimiter the splitter so let's do that and when we look at the head of this function
this is what we get so now this is present as a new column in the india data frame itself so now
what we need to do is get the min and maximum salaries from this range so for example here
the minimum salary is five thousand the maximum salary is seven four nine now that also we can
be doing with a lambda function essentially remember that this is a list and what we are
going to do is apply a lambda function which takes the zeroth element of the list and then
takes the first element of the list now we know that zeroth element of the list is the minimum
salary so we simply call it s min and the first element of the list is basically s max which is
the upper bound of the salary so let's run that and we see that something has failed it's basically
said that the list index is out of range what has gone wrong here let's take a look one of the
these are you know the reasons why it might have gone wrong first is that we didn't write the code
properly which would have resulted in incorrect syntax but that doesn't seem to be the problem
because it has given me a specific index error if it was a syntax error it would have said that it's
a syntax error there might be something like missing values in the column that is also not
the case because we have already dropped all the missing values when we did the drop in it right
then the third option is that not all rows have two elements in the salary
range column now you see that in order for this lambda to work i need the zeroth element as i as
well as you know i need the first element and if you look at this particular error carefully you
see that it has failed at the second part that's what the arrow is showing so this particular
function ran perfectly fine which means that after the split is done it is able to find the
zeroth element all the time but in some cases it's not able to find the first element the only reason
that can happen is that the string contains only one element some cases it just doesn't contain
anything so let's see what happens to those cases where the string did not contain two elements
well now we know that the salary range column each row is basically a list earlier each row
was a string which we have converted into a list by carrying out the split function so basically
each row is going to be a list now and we know how to calculate the length of a list we can just
do len and the list so what we are going to do is apply the length function to this and we are going
to capture the output in l and when we see the minimum length of the lists that are available
so this has a length of two this has a length of two all of these have a length of two right so we
would expect throughout the data frame for every list within the salary range column to have a
length of two right but that's not what is happening if we look at the minimum of list we see that there
are definitely some lists which have a length of only one now let's see why this happened one of
the reasons why that could happen is like that let's see you see that we have this data set
where the salary range is simply greater than five thousand and the s min is simply greater
than five thousand now you see that these are rows which don't contain a hyphen at all
we were counting on that hyphen to be able to split the minimum salary and the maximum salary
but if there is no hyphen if your salary is actually more than five hundred thousand us
dollars then there is no such thing as a raise there isn't like a minimum hyphen maximum there's
just greater than five thousand right so that is why we did not end up with a minimum value at all
so in order to get the maximum salary we already have the minimum salary which is simply our s min
now in order to get the maximum salary what we have to do is modify our lambda function a little bit
so now this is the function that failed it simply said that get the first value which is
this particular value out of it now of course some of them didn't have the hyphen at all so
you know it might have ended up with a list with a single element element so there was no first
element there was only the zeroth element so what we are going to do is modify the lambda function
such that we say that if the length of x is two then give us x1 otherwise give us the zeroth value
so let's do that and then we have a s min x max this time it ran properly by the way these things
that you keep seeing these are just warnings they are not errors and that's okay it's okay to ignore
them for now and then when we look at s min these are now the individual objects that we see and
these are pure numbers they are still objects but they are at least able to be converted into
numbers we can just do an as type int as we did earlier and then convert them into numbers
whereas you see in the max column again we'll still have this greater than five thousand
side so a greater than you know five hundred thousand now what we need to do is get rid of
that greater than five thousand and cap it there now if it's greater than five hundred thousand we
don't know how how large it can go so let's just use whatever we have let's use the upper bound as
the maximum salary itself and what we're going to do then is simply replace again like earlier we
replace the dollar or the comma we replace the greater than sign with an empty string and so
there it is now we have an s min let's take a look at
salary range the salary min and the salary max columns and there we are so we have the
salary range which we computed by splitting five thousand becomes the minimum salary
and seven four nine nine becomes the maximum salary let's also take a look at the
bottom few rows just like head shows the top five rows tail shows the bottom five rows so there it is
you see zero is the minimum salary 9.99 is the first salary so minimum maximum becomes a little
bit like that now let's see if we can convert the s min column here into integers for that we can
use the as type int and as earlier we can simply use the hist function to check the histogram so
now we have managed to get a numerical column out of a bunch of categorical columns so let's run that
and this is what we see we see that most people have a salary of less than what is it
50 000 us dollars so basically that makes sense and very few people have salaries that are more
than 50 000 us dollars some of them have all the way up to 500 000 so there are definitely the
disparity you see that there is a lot of room at the there is a lot of crowd at the bottom a lot
of people are earning less than 50 000 per year well by indian standards that may be a good amount
of money but remember that there are still a bunch of people far ahead of that particular curve now
in order to see this a little more you know in detail we simply increase the number of bins this
is 10 by default and we are just going to increase it by the bins to 50 and we are going to limit our
x-axis to 0 and 100 000 so basically our x-axis goes all the way from 0 to 500 000 we just want
to since most of our data is concentrated in this particular bin we are setting the x limit so this
is what the set xlim function does it basically sets the x limit to between 0 and 100 000 and
then we are also changing the number of bins so there we are so this is basically how it looks like
most of the data as we saw is concentrated between these two bins but if we magnify that
particular limit and increase the number of bins this is what we see again so most people again
like roughly 1400 people are earning less than or equal to
10 000 per annum and fewer and fewer people keep on getting higher salaries and that
makes sense this is also called a Pareto distribution or a power law distribution
where most people will be earning very will be earning lower salaries and as the salaries
goes on increasing more and more people start you know fewer and fewer people rather start
earning those higher amounts of salary right so then how do we examine some other non-numerical
columns remember that this is still univariate analysis let's take a look at one other non-numerical
column or a categorical column q5 which is select the title which is most similar to your current
role this is basically your designation or your job choice or your job title and let's take a look
so we have things like software engineer other business analysts data scientists software
engineer and so on if you look at the value counts we see that there are these many unique
designations within the indian data set most frequently the ones that are occurred are
software engineer and data scientists of course this being data from kaggle which is a platform
primarily for data scientists it's not surprising that a lot of people show up here what is
surprising though is there are 600 more than 600 data scientists there are more than 600 software
engineers but there are only 300 data analysts so what this means is that perhaps data analyst is
not a very popular job title amongst people other is just sort of a catch-all term for you know any
other job title that you may have which doesn't fall into any of the other categories there are
very few database engineers and administrators that is well that's not surprising now if i
wanted to see the proportion of all of these one of the quick ways i could do that is you've seen
that we have a plot function and we used it to plot a bar chart and a pie chart before so we're
just going to plot the bar chart again on this particular value counts output so there it is
basically it tells me that there are about 600 odd data scientists and data engineers but half of
them in fact it's really weird that the top two most frequently occurring
designations are data scientists and software engineers and the second designation and the
third most frequent designation that occurs is almost half of the first two which is weird
usually you'll see some spot of a smooth curve over here but this is interesting that's kind of
an anomaly this means that you know kaggle in india is more or less completely dominated by
data scientists and software engineers now you see this isn't very readable so you can also plot
a bar edge which is a horizontal bar chart that creates something like this so this is slightly
more readable because you can read the titles and you know the length of the bars anyway indicate
the proportion in which they are present so these are two independent kinds of univariate analysis
we have done we took a numerical column well we manufactured first a numerical column we saw its
histogram we saw what the behavior of salaries is and then we simply did counting on a categorical
column and saw the proportion of them but here's an example of a bivariate analysis which i will
start as an exercise which job title has the highest average salary so think about this how
are we going to do this basically we want to say that get all the data scientists compute their
salaries get the average get all the software engineers compute the average salary and report it
and that's what we want to do for every job title and then we want to figure out
which job title has the highest average salary now of course what do we mean by salary we in
fact have two columns s we add s min and x s max so which of them do we consider as the salary
well let's take s min because that way we are you know preparing an analysis for the worst
possible scenario that is if we find a reasonable output even by considering s min then we know that
even if you are at the lower edge of whatever you could be earning it's still a good outlook
so let's simply take s min as the salary s max is a little optimistic let's go with you know
the very conservative or the worst case possible approach over here so let's say that s min is the
actual salary that you're earning and then we want to figure out given that s min is the salary
which particular job title has the most
has the highest average salary and now what do we mean by average again then
is that to reiterate we pick a particular title let's say data scientist find all the data
scientists in that particular data frame calculate the average of all their salaries which is s min
and then find out which of these particular roles has the highest average so think about this try
to break it down into smaller steps and then we'll see about how to solve this feel free to pause
the video look around and come back when you have a solution well let's get started and see how we
can basically break this down well one of the first thing we need to do is capture in some variable
all of the different job titles that we already have we can do that straight away by looking at
this variable so there it is these are all the different titles we have and these are their
accounts so let's just call it this job let's call this particular variable job title counts
equal to the value counts of the q5 column so then job title counts this is what it looks like
then what i need to do is filter the original data set by each of these values take the s min
value out of them sum them up and basically divide it by this number because that's the
number of times it appears so that would then give me the average so what i can do is i want
to iterate over this value now one of the things about iterating over a particular series is that
remember that it basically behaves like a dictionary so it would be something like
for job title which is the key and then count which is the value in job title counts
dot vector items and i can just do print job title and count just to ensure that my iteration
is happening properly and it seems like it is i have the job title and i have the count against
it so my job title and count variables are in the iterative loop are working correctly as expected
so what i can do is create a small df which is something like i take xdf and then i take the
q5 column such that it matches this particular job title so basically i have the small df which is
a subset of the oops sorry this should not be x this should be india
so out of the india slice of the data set we want to take the fifth column and filter it with the
particular job title and we are of course iterating on all of them so that small df and
let's just break this loop over here to find out if you know we are actually doing this iteration
correctly so what break does is that after just one step of iteration it's just going to pick
okay so let's do that and let's take a look at small df dot head nothing special but you see that
q5 is basically data scientist and that makes sense the first item was data scientist it just
took you know the data scientist in the first level of iteration and broke the data set so this
is my data frame for all the people who have the designation of a data scientist now what i'm going
to do is simply pick the salary column which is small df and then i can do just smin because
earlier as we decided we are going to use smin as the salary and then i'm just going to do a
salary dot sum you remember that's how you do a salary but let's break it anyway and see if we
can get the salary column properly so if you look at salary here's what we get so basically the
sixth person in the data set has a salary of 10,000 the 76 percent has a salary of 20,000
and so on some people have 5,000 some people have 4,000 and so on i can just do a salary dot sum to
get the totals oh that didn't work you see i wanted to basically do some of the salary but it all
you know got converted into a big string which means that the salaries that we're looking at
are not basically integers when i do a salary dot head it basically says that the data type is object
well in that case let's just do a salary dot as type integer which is fine and then when i do a
sum gives me something which is a number which is not that crazy string that it gave me earlier
what it did earlier was that it simply concatenated all the strings which is why i was getting a big
string so when you do a sum on a column that contains string it's going to concatenate the
strings it's not going to produce the numerical result even if the string actually represents
a number that is simply because we haven't done this as type integer step so there it is i can
simply add this over here i can do something like as type integer and then i can say
total salary for title is salary dot sum and then i can say average
salary for title
is equal to well total salary for title divided by the count because counts i am getting from here
anyway right that becomes my average salary now in order to contain all this data i'll create
a dictionary let's just call it salaries which is an empty dictionary what i'm going to do is that
i'm going to put the designation inside the dictionary which is job title and the value
is going to be the average salary for the title so let's run this and print what we get in
salads there is a name error it says that salary is not defined well it's not salary it's salaries
so there it is we have corrected the name and we see that the average salary of a data scientist
in india is twenty three thousand dollars that of a software engineer is much lower which is
thirteen thousand dollars that of a data analyst is well surprisingly less than that of a software
engineer which is thirteen thousand three seventy five it's a difference of five hundred dollars
per year which is still a sizable amount and there is the other field which has a high salary
but then you know the other you know it's just a collection of whatever fields didn't already
now you see that this is basically a dictionary one of the things i could simply do is put that
dictionary back into a series and plot it as a bar chart again
so there it is so we see that product managers and project managers are the most followed by data
scientists followed by research scientists followed by business analysts followed by
statisticians and so on so that's what our data looks like now again in the spirit of keeping
things modular and fast all of this jugglery can be avoided so let's see how we can basically change
our code you see that here we calculated the sum then divided it by count this was not really
instead of sum i can just call it mean and then this becomes my
average salary for title of course that as type int i've already done so this should work
and then i can completely get rid of this time so i have that and then again i get the same plot
so this works well one of the other things we could straight away do is use the group by
statement what we are doing is we have covered by the way group by an aggregation in one of the
earlier videos what we are going to do is we are going to take india and we are going to group it
by the q5 column what this means is that it's going to group the entire data set by each unique
value present in the q5 column out of that those groups we are going to select the salary min
column we are going to convert it into an integer and then we are going to simply take the mean of
it so that's how group by an aggregation works and there is a problem okay so apparently you
cannot access callable attribute as type so let's do something else we'll just convert smin into an
integer beforehand so it's basically not letting me convert integer types as part of the group by
operation so i'm just going to move the as type and outside and i'm going to then calculate the
grouped means of the salary column separately so there we are and we see we have more or less the
same data however we can also plot this as a bar chart and here we have so there it is of course
it's occurring a little weirdly if i wanted to basically make this entire chart a little
more readable i would basically put this data in a variable called salaries and then what i would do
is i would do sort values on salaries so that i get a nice readable chart like this where i
go from low to high and then i would basically do a plot and there we are so yeah this is a lot
more readable we see that product and project managers on the most data scientists on
the second most but you see that there is a big drop so you see managers are
a lot more than most other people you have research scientists business analysts
who earn a fair amount of money right this is basically the order in which they go
now you see that the people who earn the least amount of money in this whole thing are data
analysts but if you think about it really carefully a business analyst and a data analyst
are more or less the same thing now this is a you know a hack that you might want to learn from
your job title really matters on your CV so basically if you are a data analyst try to
call yourself a business analyst wherever possible because that alone seems to indicate a much higher
minimum salary remember that we are still talking about s min
so these are the lower worst case scenarios so to be very frank business analysts and data analysts
they don't do things that are very widely different they do things that are fairly
similar to each other so that is why if i mean the point is again that job titles matter and
precisely how they matter well this is how they matter this is basically the average
salary of each job title that you have now there are a lot of other columns present in the data
set you can look at them there are columns that talk about education so you can also repeat the
same exercise and say what sort of education qualification earns the most salaries what sort
of software tools or expertise with certain software tools is likely to get you more salaries
whatever does education correlate with titles so how many data scientists have a PhD for example
so you can do all sorts of these bivariate analysis combinations and i encourage them
i encourage you to try them out so that is probably how you do univariate and bivariate
analysis to tell stories with data essentially here we have a clear-cut understanding of how
salaries are reflected across multiple job titles so do take a look on your own
with more and more columns in the data set and try to see what you come up with
you